vamos a retomar el fútbol italiano
porque al margen del desarrollo de la
serie Ay ese título que acaricia el
Napoli los equipos de este país están
completando un gran desempeño en Europa
inter y Milán están en semifinales de
Champions la juve y la Roma están entre
los cuatro mejores de la Europa League y
la fiorentina está peleando por meterse
en la final de la conferencia League
para analizar ese tema está con nosotros
Sara Castro directora de deportes de
Caracol radio y del diario as Colombia
bienvenida Sara Hola Juan como siempre
un gusto estar con ustedes Así es Muchas
gracias a ti estamos aquí para hablar de
fútbol sala está viviendo el fútbol
italiano un Renacer de esas épocas
doradas cuando era la mejor liga del
mundo ya sabemos que por lo menos en
Champions habrá un equipo italiano en la
final intero Milán Pues bueno Yo creo
que es muy interesante hablar de una
refundación de este futbol italiano que
además viene de unos análisis muy serios
a partir de la no clasificación de la
selección italiana justamente los dos
últimos mundiales de fútbol yo creo que
a partir de ahí el fútbol italiano
empieza a preguntarse básicamente en
tres sentidos uno
liga italiana es lo suficientemente
competitiva dos si tienen o le dan tanta
visibilidad al talento local y tres si
este concepto del catenazo que durante
muchos años
vinculó al fútbol italiano con Los
Grandes lugares de la competencia
internacional es el que corresponde en
este momento histórico por el que
atraviesa el fútbol mundial creo que en
primer lugar en esta Champions podemos
hablar de suerte en el sorteo
evidentemente Los Fuertes los demás
jerarquía de esta Champions League
quedaron en el otro lado del cuadro pero
lo que estamos viendo son unos proyectos
de reconstrucción interesantes porque
porque se buscaron jugadores del mercado
interno que fortalecen todas esas
escuadras Porque también se ha ido a
otros mercados a encontrar talentos como
cabarethelia que sin duda están dándole
al fútbol italiano un Renacer pero
también desde el punto de vista de los
entrenadores yo creo que lo que estamos
viendo con spalletti Napoli con insai en
el inter
con Enzo italiano en Florentina
son otros puntos de vista del fútbol que
son interesantes para enriquecer como
competitivamente pueden competir estos
clubes italianos a nivel internacional
si bien las dudas sobre el calcio siguen
presentes yo creo que lo que se ha
conseguido es recobrar un poco de esa
identidad competitiva y es lo que
estamos viendo en la Champions sin duda
la caída del nápoli después de esta
fortaleza en la serie fue bastante
sorprendente pero creo que suele pasar
con equipos que están muy enfocados en
alguno de estos torneos Ahora yo creo
que evidentemente estamos muy lejos de
esa década dorada que fue 1991 al 2001
donde los equipos italianos además por
fortaleza económica tenían otro otro
tipo de contrataciones y de proyectos
pero creo que esta refundación del
fútbol italiano ahora en manos de grupos
inversores pues necesitaba dar esta
vuelta y creo que a partir de la crisis
están reconstruyendo cosas que pueden
llegar a ser interesantes lo que aporta
técnicos como pioli o como mourinho ya
con más experiencia equipos como la Roma
o como el Milan creo que también está
dando pues frutos en un fútbol que
necesitaba encontrar de nuevo como esa
chispa que lo hiciera competir a gran
nivel en entornos internacionales ese
fútbol de los 90 con los que en mi caso
cuando era niño yo me ilusionaba
viéndolo en la tele todos los cracks
exactamente unos grandes referentes
Aprovechando que estamos hablando del
Milan en inter en este lado de la
Champions hablemos de esta de la
Champions League porque esta semana se
definieron las semifinales en el otro
lado del cuadro tenemos al Real Madrid y
al Manchester City hablemos de este
emparejamiento que también es muy
atractivo no impresionante yo creo que
son los dos en las dos plantillas
con el mejor talento de Europa sin duda
estamos hablando de Manchester City y
del Real Madrid a ver qué podemos hacer
el Real Madrid que ya nos haya dicho
tiene un técnico que entiende muy bien
Cuál es el concepto de juego que quiere
proponer y sobre todo con el que pondré
si esa jerarquía que ya le conocemos en
torneos internacionales Entonces el
parte de un orden táctico un orden
defensivo que lo que le permite es que
ese talento diferencial que él tiene de
para adelante empieza a surgir Entonces
le pide a sus jugadores mucho compromiso
a la hora de defender a la hora de ser
colectivos Y de esa forma yo creo que en
el segundo partido contra el Chelsea se
vio un equipo que sí le puso un poco de
problemas pero luego supo sobreponerse
esa presión del primer tiempo y logró
sacar lo mejor
ancelotti es un técnico que ha hecho
mejor a Rodrigo que ha hecho mejor a
vinicius que ahora le está dando la
oportunidad a camavinga pero que al
tiempo tiene unas unas personalidades y
y unos jugadores de una jerarquía
impresionante como lo son modric que lo
que lo pone como interior como son Cross
y una serie de jugadores Así que creo
que este Real Madrid no solo cuenta con
esa mentalidad que tienen los equipos
que ya están acostumbrados a ganar sino
que tiene un equipo muy bien conformado
y que sabe muy bien cómo pelear esta
Champions yendo rápidamente al
Manchester City estamos viendo el equipo
más consistente Sólido y arrasador yo
creo que a nivel europeo le está
poniendo en problemas Incluso en la
primera al Arsenal que llevaba una buena
cantidad de puntos acumulados de pareja
qué es lo que quiero decir de este City
que ha aprendido también a ser
pragmático Y creo que eso para un
entrenador como Pep Guardiola dice
muchas cosas si vienen nunca va a
salirse de sus principios base de eso
que él entiende con el fútbol posicional
un fútbol de Posesión también que
siempre Busca hacer daño lo hemos visto
entregando un poco más la pelota al
rival y entendiendo aprovechar los
momentos de partido y eso creo que es
fundamental un jaland que es
impresionante y luego también un nuevo
esquema táctico con un tres dos cuatro
uno que que no se lo hemos visto al City
creo que ya el city está preparado para
asumir la presión la presión No desde el
punto de vista negativo sino como algo
que hay que disfrutar porque ya se lo ha
ganado